this morning we're going to take a look
at the economic toll of the pandemic to
millions of people as you know out of
work right now and they're self-employed
or they run small businesses normally
they would not qualify for unemployment
but in many states they are now eligible
for help from a program created more
than a month ago our consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Warner
found that many people are struggling to
get that money another wrinkle to the
story and a good morning to you good
morning Gail and that's right that is
badly needed money for so many people
with small businesses including one man
in Texas who's been running his one-man
business for 12 years since the crisis
hit self-employed handyman Terry Crane
has only been able to get a few jobs
people don't a lot of strangers and into
their home because they're afraid of
bringing the virus in with him his
income now doesn't cover his bills yet
he says when he called the Texas
unemployment office in March and again
in April he was told he didn't qualify
and they said well you'll get a letter
that will explain everything to you so
far haven't got that letter he says he
hasn't gotten a stimulus check either
and he may not be able to cover his $370
a month mortgage luckily I had some
savings but that is almost gone what do
you have left right now as of last night
I had $197 left that's not enough no no
that doesn't pay the bills like Crain
many people who are self-employed or run
their own small businesses say they're
having trouble getting unemployment
benefits due to the pandemic Congress
set up a special program for these
people who previously would not have
been eligible it's called the pandemic
unemployment assistance program or PUA
but it's set up to be run by the states
and as of Thursday only thirty states
have started making payments and many
people are struggling to fight their way
through the system even in states where
it has been set up in Morro Bay
California Therese favela runs a small
dog grooming business
California's shelter in place order
forced her to close in March she was
allowed to reopen Monday my account with
negative
it's at there- and it just kept
everything snowballing what happened
with unemployment unemployment that's
like a mystery because I applied and I'm
in the system but my profile it says
that I have zero balance zero dollars
it's most rating she applied in late
March but California's PUA program
wasn't ready to process applications
until April 28th it's a similar story in
Virginia for Robin Ferguson who runs a
knitting and yarn store everything was
on the uptick and I was chuggins
right uphill and then she applied on
Virginia's unemployment site but could
never get her application to go through
and gave up instead she's making what
money she can hand I infer curbside
pickup and offering home deliveries
we're running for over a month now with
no assistance what do you think of that
it's discouraging the Virginia
Employment Commission told us their
system was overwhelmed and said they've
since launched a new website with an
outside contractor we clearly need to do
a better job of getting these programs
out labor specialist Jesse Rothstein at
the University of california-berkeley
says state governments just weren't
ready and he sees problems with the way
many set up their programs they told
people they first had to apply it apply
for a [ __ ] unemployment insurance get
rejected and then they could be could
apply for the for the new program but
people didn't get the message that that
was just a step in the process they got
the message that they've been rejected
for benefits and now I think we're
gradually sorry to catch up but there
are still people who are being missed
and that's a huge problem but dog
groomer Teresa favela got good news this
week she'll be getting a federal loan
what's kept her going until now she says
it's her community the people who are
okay are very supportive thank you as
you can see a lot of confusion here
after our interviews Terry Crain and
Robin Ferguson reached out to their
respective state unemployment
departments again and tried again
fingers crossed that they will be
getting some money now as we said 30
states we have a list of those states on
our website CBS news.com you can go and
check that out and see what is going on
in your state Anthony yeah great
information Anna so many small
businesses are burning through savings
right now and state systems are just
overwhelmed it's really and the numbers
just keep going up as we see thanks Anna